FINAL NEWS CONFERENCE.
RICH EDSON WAS AT THE NEWS
CONFERENCE AND REPORTS FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
>> SECRETARY REX TILLERSON WITH
ONLY HOURS REMAINING LEADING THE
STATE DEPARTMENT SAID GOODBYE,
WARNING OF UNRESOLVED CHALLENGES
IN SYRIA AND WITH CHINA AND
RUSSIA.
>> RUSSIA MUST ASSESS CAREFULLY
AS TO HOW ITS ACTIONS ARE IN THE
BEST INTERESTS OF THE RUSSIAN
PEOPLE AND THE WORLD MORE
BROADLY.
CONTINUING ON THEIR CURRENT
TRAJECTORY IS LIKELY TO LEAD TO
GREATER ISOLATION ON THEIR PART.
>> TILLERSON DISAGREED WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON SEVERAL
ISSUES.
RUSSIA, QATAR, THE PARIS CLIMATE
RECORD.
>> I DON'T THINK ANYONE DOUBTS
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE OR THE
COMMITMENT OF THE GOVERNMENT TO
ADVANCING VALUES AND DEFENDING
VALUES.
THE PRESIDENT SPEAKS FOR
HIMSELF.
>> PRIMARILY THE IRAN NUCLEAR
AGREEMENT.
THIS MORNING THE PRESIDENT CITED
IT AS A REASON FOR THE CHANGE IN
STATE.
AND IN AUGUST, TILLERSON
PUBLICLY ACKNOWLEDGED THEY
DISAGREED ON IRAN.
>> HE AND I HAVE DIFFERENCES OF
VIEWS ON THINGS LIKE JCPOA AND
HOW WE SHOULD USE IT.
WE HAVE DIFFERENCES.
I THINK IF WE ARE NOT HAVING
THOSE DIFFERENCES, I'M NOT SURE
I AM SERVING HIM.
>> TILLERSON HAS LOBBIED THE
ADMINISTRATION TO REMAIN IN THE
IRAN NUCLEAR WOMEN.
HIS DATE OF ARTMAN HAS BEEN
NEGOTIATED AND CHANGES TO AROUND
POLICY WITH EUROPEAN ALLIES TO
KEEP THE U.S. AND THE DEAL.
TILLERSON HAS NOMINATED --
SUCCESSOR MIKE POMPEO IS A
LONGTIME CRITIC OF THE
AGREEMENT.
>> MISSILE TESTS, ACTIVITY OF
SHIITE MILITIAS IN -- SHIA
MILITIAS.
THEIR ACTIVITY HAS DRAMATICALLY
INCREASED.
>> SPECULATION PAGE THAT THE
PRESIDENT WOULD FIRE TILLERSON
IN THE FALL.
HE STAYED.
AIDES AT STATE ASSUMED HE WOULD
REMAIN.
CONGRESSIONAL AIDES SAY
RELATIONS WITH CONGRESS IMPROVE.
HE TRAVELED MORE AND SPEND A
LITTLE MORE TIME WITH THE PRESS.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THERE'S PEOPLE
IN THE WHITE HOUSE WHO DON'T
WANT YOU TO BE SECRETARY OF
STATE?
TO GO I DON'T KNOW.
>> SECRETARY TILLERSON CLOSE
THINKING SENIOR STAFF AND THOSE
WHO WORKED WITH ACROSS THE STATE
DEPARTMENT AND OTHER
DEPARTMENTS, ESPECIALLY THE
MILITARY.